merci d'être avec nous Roger caoutchi et
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénateur les républicains des
Hauts-de-Seine premier vice-président du
Sénat on va évidemment longuement parler
de la réforme des retraites on a entendu
hier en introduction des débats Gabriel
Attal le ministre des comptes publics a
lancé à la majorité un appel à la
responsabilité à la cohérence vous
entendez cet appel
oui
gouvernement en réalité a repris les
propositions du groupe les républicains
du Sénat depuis 2018 donc 64 ans 43
annuités on dit ça et on vote ça au
Sénat depuis 2018 c'est dommage qu'on
est autant tardé parce que on aurait
fait cette réforme des retraites en 2018
les conditions matérielles financières
de l'équilibre ont été plus facile à
trouver mais bon alors
était moins rude elle aurait témoin rude
parce que il y avait encore un peu de
marge on a on est resté cinq ans sans
réforme et évidemment ça a cru le
déficit bon maintenant nous avons un
certain nombre de propositions
d'amendements sur les maires de famille
sur les carrières longues sur l'emploi
des seniors si le gouvernement nous suit
là-dessus globalement nous considérons
que le texte va dans le bon sens et nous
le voterons mais nous ne voterons pas
pour faire plaisir au gouvernement nous
disons gouvernement c'est une réforme
qui nous convient parce que c'était une
autre depuis des années merci de nous
avoir rejoint merci de répondre à nos
propositions et si c'est le cas on vote
ça veut dire que vous demandez au
gouvernement de vous rallier à votre
réforme telle qu'elle sera votée par le
China il y a pas de compromis possibles
c'est votre réforme non parce que tout
le monde est bien conscient nous les
premiers que le passage à 64 ans ou à 43
ennuité 43 nut c'est la réforme Touraine
donc souhaité par les socialistes
pendant le mandat de François Hollande
mais on sait bien enfin franchement
vous croyez que ça fait plaisir de dire
aux gens il faut travailler plus
bien sûr qu'on préfère et dire on a
tellement d'argent on a tellement un
équilibre formidable qu'on vous demande
rien de plus et c'est pas la peine de
travailler plus mais on sait qu'il faut
demander aux gens de travailler plus ça
ne plaît pas ça ne plaît pas de demander
de travailler plus parce qu'on sait bien
que c'est un effort donc en parallèle il
faut qu'on ait quand même des avancées
sur d'autres éléments d'un équilibre sur
les carrières longues je l'ai dit sur la
maternité sur un certain nombre de
sujets la politique familiale pour moi
c'est un élément essentiel pourquoi
parce que on n'arrête pas de dire il
faut un rééquilibrage entre actif et
retraités si vous n'aidez pas la
natalité si vous n'aidez pas les
familles vous n'avez pas de possibilité
de trouver un équilibre actif retraité
donc il faut une politique familiale par
une politique nataliste pour vous tant
qu'on est sur le système par répartition
une évidence puisque le nombre d'actifs
et le nombre de retraités sont liés sur
les versements donc oui bien sûr vous
parlez de vos propositions Gabriel Attal
a alerté sur le coup de vos mesures 800
millions environ pour le CDI senior 100
millions pour les retraites progressives
et un coup important a-t-il dit pour la
surcote pour les maires de famille sans
le chiffrer vous entendez cette alerte
j'entends mais en parallèle j'ai vu que
sur un certain nombre de sujets le
gouvernement était avancé à mon avis
sans réellement avoir chiffré et quand
on me dit que évidemment la mesure pour
les maires de famille a un coût mais un
coup immédiat
dans 20 ans dans 30 ans lorsque on aura
soutenu la natalité dans ce pays est-ce
qu'on récupérera pas ces sommes et
beaucoup plus largement même que ces
sommes donc il faut faire des
investissements à terme il faut
accompagner les gens se disant si on
veut que le système de retraite soit
durable il faut pas regarder à 2 ans ou
à 5 ans il faut regarder à 20 ans ceci
étant je suis le premier à dire que un
système de retraite il est pas éternel
donc il y aura d'autres réformes dans
les années qui viennent et ça veut dire
que ça c'est une première étape et que
une fois qu'on arrive à un rééquilibrage
budgétaire sur les retraites faudra
revoir complètement je l'avais dit ça
déjà dans l'hémicycle quelle est la
relation avec le travail pourquoi autant
de jeunes n'ont pas envie de rentrer
dans le monde du travail pourquoi est-ce
que le monde du travail s'est figé
pourquoi on ne change pas la nature des
choses moi je suis prêt à tous les
débats sur le nombre d'heures de travail
sur l'organisation des journées sur la
relation au travail les entreprises tout
ça ce sont de vrais sujets on peut pas
tout faire en même temps alors
rééquilibrant les comptes pour qu'on ait
ni à baisser les pensions ni accroître
les cotisations et en même temps
réfléchissons à ce qu'elle travaille
aujourd'hui mais ces mesures les mesures
que vous proposez ont un coût et les
républicains disent qu'ils sont attachés
à l'équilibre et qu'il faut faire
attention à ce que cette réforme
rapporte quand même des suffisamment
pour sauver le système comment du coup
vous allez compenser quelles sont les
économies qu'il faut faire il y a
plusieurs mesures vous avez vu que par
exemple nous proposons la biométrie sur
les retraites à l'étranger nous
proposons un certain nombre de mesures
sur la fraude sociale ça va compenser
oui parce que bon je veux pas rentrer
dans un débat démagogique sur les
chiffres mais clairement oui parce que
les mesures que l'on propose en
parallèle d'accompagnement son coûteux
c'est vrai mais pas
inabordable et par rapport à la
l'équilibre même de la réforme ça reste
un niveau qui permet de dire que cette
réforme elle a un objectif et elle aura
des résultats sur les carrières longues
puisque vous le dites c'est le un des
autres sujets ça n'a pas été tranché en
commission et il y a des divergences
entre les républicains de l'assemblée et
les républicains du Sénat quel est votre
position est-ce qu'il faut rentrer dans
un dispositif où personne ne travaille
au delà de 43 ans non moi je suis pour
que le cas échéant et on la proposait il
y a des surcotes de 5% au-delà de la
banque mais dire que on veut rentrer
dans un système extrêmement figé non sur
les il y a une autre question et là pour
le coup il y a un amendement issu des
sénateurs LR de certains sénateurs LR
c'est un introduction d'une part de
capitalisation est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable oui j'ai signé d'ailleurs
qu'aux signé une tribune
sur cette ouverture à une capitalisation
de capitalisation collective et ouverte
à tout le monde donc ça existe dans le
public ça existe dans le public moi j'en
ai bénéficié si je puis dire j'ai été
inspecteur général de l'Éducation
nationale et je cotisais à ce système
donc je vois pas pourquoi ce serait pas
ouvert au prix avec le fait de dire
qu'il faut faire cette réforme pour
sauver le régime par répartition parce
que si on passe à un capitalisation ce
sont les Français les plus riches qui
vont ce n'est pas vrai moi je suis pas
la sauvegarde du système à repartition
parce que ça permet à chacun de se dire
j'ai un matelas je sais ce que j'ai de
base après que les gens veuillent faire
eux-mêmes pendant leur vie active un
effort pour se dire je veux plus et ben
moi ça me paraît pas un conséquent s'ils
se disent bah je fais un effort là pour
avoir plus à l'arrivée parce que je sais
que plus âgé je serai plus fragile je
fais les formes maintenant en quoi
est-ce que c'est un sondage et
innommable non il faut laisser un peu de
liberté il y a un autre sujet c'est la
question des régimes spéciaux qui là non
plus n'a pas été tranché en commission
ni le gouvernement ni vos alliés
centristes ou ne sont favorables à votre
position qui est d'accélérer la
suppression des régimes vous allez
continuer à la fin de cette proposition
du gouvernement est décentrée ce qui est
de dire c'est ce qu'on appelle la clause
du grand-père c'est à dire bon ne sont
pas ne sont pas touchés tous ceux qui
sont déjà en poste bon le groupe elle
est la commission d'ailleurs avait
envisagé de dire
convergence en 15 ou 20 ans dans 15 ou
20 ans pas avec des compensations
compensation salariale compensation en
trimestre de cotisations rajouter donc
ça n'était pas non plus une mesure
brutale mais voilà si il faut un accord
global avec les centristes trouvons-le
donc c'est là vous êtes prêt à lâcher ce
que c'est pas c'est pas une ligne rouge
c'est ce que vous redoutez pas aussi
parce que c'est un peu ce que disent les
centriste que cette mesure elle alimente
la contestation et l'alimente la journée
du 7 mars c'est toujours pareil
soit on arrive à bien expliquer et le
délai est un peu court soit on dit que
c'est pas une ligne rouge on va
continuer à parler évidemment de ce
texte puisque la gauche veut se faire
entendre elle dépose des motions
d'émotions référendaires hier ça a été
examiné en séance en tout cas d'émotion
de rejet on va voir ça avec notre
journaliste parlementaire si le Jourdain
[Musique]
bonjour et le retour de suivre
on a vu le Sénat a commencé à examiner
la réforme des retraites et la gauche a
tenter de marquer son territoire oui pas
une seconde à perdre l'idée est de
rappeler son opposition au projet du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire au recul de
l'âge de départ à 64 ans rappelle que
c'est na il n'y a pas de nupes mais
trois groupes de gauche différents les
socialistes 64 sénateurs les communistes
15 sénateurs et les écologistes 12
sénateurs à gauche il ne porte pas le
même maillot mais il partage les mêmes
objections sur la réforme ils vont
d'ailleurs tenter de coordonner leurs
actions et leurs arguments durant
l'examen du texte le mot d'ordre a été
résumé par le socialiste Rémi Féraud
c'était hier juste avant le début de la
séance
notre stratégie c'est la combativité pas
l'obstruction la combativité
parce que tous les amendements que nous
déposons sont des amendements de fond il
n'y a pas d'amendement qui soit
cosmétique ou de purpente ça non mais
par ailleurs si le Sénat comme
l'assemblée avant elle n'a pas le temps
nécessaire suffisant pour discuter cette
loi la responsabilité en reviendra au
gouvernement par l'utilisation de
l'article 47 1 de la Constitution et
parmi les objections posées gouvernement
il y a la question de la méthode oui la
gauche a déposée plusieurs notions dites
de procédure l'idée est de rejeter le
texte avant même de l'examiner les
communistes reprochent par exemple au
gouvernement d'avoir choisi de passer
cette réforme par un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
eux aucun doute ce choix réel relève du
coût de force écoutez monsieur le
président
du CCP de délibérer d'un texte
qui vote de l'Assemblée nationale je le
rappelle les députés sont élus au
suffrage universel direct
l'accepter l'accepter
l'accepter participe au coup de force
engagé par le président de la République
contre les institutions pour imposer
cette réforme massivement rejetée une
position partagée par les écologistes et
les socialistes Guillaume Gontard le
patron des écolos a dénoncé la
limitation du temps de débat au
Parlement on rappelle que l'article 47-1
permet au gouvernement de limiter le
temps d'examen dans l'hémicycle 20 jours
maximum à l'Assemblée nationale 15 jours
maximum au Sénat au total ça fait 11
jours de séances ici à la Chambre haute
c'est beaucoup trop peu pour Guillaume
motard
urgence pourquoi ce passage en force
pourquoi ce festival des mensonges
pourquoi cette contrainte du débarque
parlementaire en fait tout simplement
pourquoi refuser le débat pourquoi parce
que vous ne voulez tout simplement pas
qu'on parle du fond vous ne voulez pas
parler de votre projet dans le fond et
si toutes les notion de procédure
déposée par la gauche ont été rejetées
hier c'est donc parti ça veut dire que
l'examen peut commencer bah ça c'était
sans compter sans la motion référendaire
la motion référendaire elle s'inscrit
dans le cadre de l'article 11 de la
Constitution et consiste et bien à
proposer au président de la République
de soumettre un texte à référendum en
l'occurrence la réforme des retraites
cette notion a été déposée par la gauche
elle sera examinée ce matin par les
sénateurs sera-t-elle adoptée par le
Sénat Roger caoutchi vous allez la voter
cette notion
[Rires]
après tout c'est pas une mauvaise idée
pourquoi ne pas soumettre cette réforme
à référendum
mais alors on soumet aussi un référendum
le texte sur l'immigration est-ce que la
gauche est d'accord c'est à dire c'est
uniquement les textes qu'il arrangent
elles qu'il faudrait soumettre à
référendum mais quand on dit nous on
veut un référendum sur l'immigration un
référendum sur la justice la gauche
chris est grand dur en disant comment
non non non surtout pas et ben alors
laissons le Parlement faire son travail
et que le Parlement le fasse
correctement c'est déjà un premier point
vous pensez que la gauche va rentrer
dans une forme d'obstruction pendant
l'examen de ce texte elle est
malheureusement bien partie je le
regrette parce que moi je suis
un défenseur absolu des pouvoirs du
Parlement et je souhaite que le
Parlement s'exprime défendent propose
que l'opposition soit respectée qu'elle
est son temps etc j'entends dire sur le
47 ans mais pardon de dire que au Sénat
nous avons prévu 100 heures de débats
sur la réforme des retraites sur le
texte l'ensemble du texte de projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale donc pas sur les que sur la
retraite surtout ça a été à l'automne
dernier 30 heures c'est à dire que
franchement senteur sur le texte
retraite c'est largement suffisant pour
s'exprimer proposer convaincre après
quand je vois que il y a trois quatre
mille amendements de la gauche c'est
évident que ça n'est pas uniquement
proposé et convaincre c'est aussi
saturer et donc faire de l'obstruction à
partir de là voilà on va voir comment
les choses se passent soit il y a une
volonté de s'exprimer ce qui est tout à
fait respectable mais de ne pas empêcher
démocratiquement la majorité de voter
parce que c'est comme ça l'émotion
d'ailleurs de procédure ont été rejetées
93 voix
240 contre la première le premier la
première règle de la démocratie c'est
que la majorité doit au terme être celle
qui l'emporte c'est ça la démocratie
parce que si 93 bloque 240 c'est plus la
démocratie et à partir de là on va voir
comment les choses évoluent dans les
jours qui viennent donc il y a beaucoup
d'amendements qui ont été déposés
effectivement par la gauche un peu plus
de 3000 vous comptez la déposer 4000
amendements au total 4000 amendements au
total les trois groupes vous comptez
faire en sorte d'accélérer les débats
parce que la droite vous êtes
majorités dans un premier temps et on
l'a dit très clairement
nous souhaitons que naturellement les
choses s'expriment que chacun dise qu'il
a à dire ça a commencé avec l'émotion
hier ça va se poursuivre aujourd'hui
dans les jours qui viennent on a bien
compris qu'il voulait faire
symboliquement le 7 quelque chose par
rapport aux manifestations et à la grève
générale cette mars mardi prochain 7
mars donc
ça vous êtes d'accord avec ça mais nous
ne sommes pas là pour brider
l'expression mais en revanche nous ne
pouvons pas accepter que 93 brides 240
parce que chacun peut comprendre que ça
n'est pas le fonctionnement normal de la
démocratie et donc
s'exprimer proposer être ce qu'ils sont
très bien mais au bout du bout on verra
bien s'ils veulent bloquer le système
aussi très logiquement on va et on
avance quels sont les outils dont vous
disposez pour débloquer ce que vous
appelez un blocage et bien vous verrez
bien dans les jours à venir donc vous
prévoyez d'utiliser certains
je l'ai déjà dit tout à l'heure moi je
suis un parlementariste convaincu
convaincu et quand j'étais ministre
chargé de relations avec le Parlement
j'ai porté ici comme à l'Assemblée la
réforme de 2008 qui donnait plus de
pouvoir au Parlement et au groupe
d'opposition et au groupe d'opposition
et j'y ai beaucoup tenu mais à un moment
le respect du Parlement c'est aussi le
respect des majorités oui mais là vous
connaissez par cœur vous la procédure
parlementaire vous avez été vous le
dites mises en relation avec le
Parlement est-ce que 4000 amendements
dans les 10 jours qui restent puisqu'il
reste plus que 10 jours ça rentre
ça tout rentre s'il y a de la bonne
volonté si une fois posé les principes
si une fois que vous avez exprimé vos
propositions vous vous voyez bien ce que
vous pouvez obtenir ou pas et à partir
de là en avant moi je vais vous dire mon
sentiment profond et je l'ai dit déjà
aujourd'hui aux élus de gauche qu'est-ce
qui est le plus démocratique que les 348
sénateurs
prépare un texte évolue avance ou de
dire au bout du bout on va vous bloquer
et vous votre épave et donc c'est la
commission mix paritaire cette sénateur
et cette députée qui vont faire le texte
qu'est-ce qui est le plus démocratique
348 ou 14 7 députés cette sénateur parce
que de toute façon il y aura un texte de
toute façon il y aura un texte donc la
symbolique du nom vote du Sénat serait
une symbolique qui d'abord rabaisserait
le Sénat on rabaisserait le Sénat c'est
pas son rôle le Sénat est là pour être à
la fois un apporteur positif et dans la
sagesse il est pas autant faire de
l'obstruction vous vous parlez de cette
CMP cette accord entre député de
sénateur qui doit être trouvé ça vous
paraît envisageable que cette CMP soit
conclusive oui je serais presque tenter
de dire heureusement ou malheureusement
oui parce que je ne suis pas un
fanatique non plus des CMP moi je
préfère les votes qui ont lieu dans les
hémicycles mais c'est quand on connaît
la majorité future de cette commission
mix paritaire il y aura un texte parce
que dans la commission expérimentale il
y a pas d'obstruction donc par
définition si on laisse la CMP agir la
CMP sortira un texte je préfère un texte
sorti de l'hémicycle des 348 on disait
tout à l'heure il y a des divergences
entre les députés et les républicains et
les sénateurs les républicains est-ce
que cette bataille pour la réforme des
retraites va laisser des traces au sein
de votre famille politique
c'est pas vraiment la bataille des
retraites c'est bon on a un petit sujet
chacun de ces je veux pas non plus sur
le groupe autour d'Aurélien Pradier pour
qui j'ai de l'estime et franchement je
comprends pas trop l'assuenchère je
pense qu'il a un avenir ce garçon mais
c'est pas une raison pour pour être trop
individualiste par rapport au collectif
donc il faut qu'on voit comment on gère
ça tranquillement sereinement sans excès
c'est pas lié qu'aux retraite c'est il y
a une affirmation mais bon
si s'il trouve bien il faudra qu'il en
respecte les règles c'est-à-dire c'est
soit il est il parle moins et en tout
cas il est moins virulent moins virulent
pas vous pouvez pas en permanence
l'amour rentrait c'est toujours l'amour
vache je pense que en réalité Aurélien
Pradier
peut-être un jour je voudrais être
sénateur et donc en attendant il nous
tape dessus mais il a tort il le sait il
faut faire du collectif le redressement
de la droite passera par unité entre les
députés les sénateurs les députés
européens nos militants nos cadres qui
ne veulent pas de division et qui
veulent l'unité merci
à tout à l'heure si on parlera de la
réforme des retraites et du tempo de
cette réforme de l'entraîneur
dans le club on va parler d'un autre
sujet c'est la qualité dans nos régions
avec nos partenaires de la presse
régionale on va aller en Haute-Vienne
Roger Carotti retrouvé Hélène pommier
journaliste santé aux populaires du sang
bonjour Hélène merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous et vous nous parlez d'un
portage que vous avez réalisé avec des
médecins en haut degienne qui menacent
de se déconventionner car il refuse les
conditions de l'assurance maladie
oui bonjour donc on a reçu en effet des
différents témoignages à la fois en
Haute-Vienne et en Corrèze de médecins
généralistes qui sont dans cette
réflexion aujourd'hui et qui assiste
notamment aux assises du
déconventionnement qui sont organisés là
aujourd'hui et demain par le syndicat de
l'Union Française pour la médecine libre
donc voilà c'est en tout cas c'est pas
forcément
quelque chose qui sont en train de
concrétiser mais il y a une réflexion en
cours voilà et vous avez la question que
je vous exactement je voulais poser une
question à Roger carochi pardon est-ce
que finalement avec
cette tentation du déconventionnement
est-ce qu'on assiste pas à la naissance
d'une on risque pas d'assister à la
naissance d'une médecine à deux vitesses
une pour les riches et une pour les
pauvres
soyons clairs ça existe déjà vous avez
déjà je parle de l'Île-de-France par
exemple que je connais bien j'avais déjà
beaucoup de médecins qui sont qui ne
sont pas conventionnés moi j'ai trouvé
dans cette affaire que la position du
gouvernement était un peu illisible
autant je suis le premier à dire que les
organisations qui disaient faut passer
la visite de 25 à 50 euros bon c'était
tellement excessif que personne ne
voyait bien de solution autant le 1 €50
d'augmentation accordée par le
gouvernement alors avec des conditions
pour ceux qui éventuellement
accepteraient des charges
supplémentaires d'augmenter c'était pas
très lisible j'aurais préféré une
négociation à ajuste milieu moi je pense
que franchement je sais bien quel
équilibre de l'assurance maladie à gérer
mais que l'ensemble des consultations
médicales soit à peu près à 30 euros
aujourd'hui ça ne m'aurait pas paru
insensé et qu'on fasse des gestes
positifs pour les médecins qui acceptent
plus de patients plus de contraintes
plus de garde alors c'était du plus pour
tout le monde si vous voulez oui parce
que
c'est rien on n'a pas augmenté le tarif
de la visite médicale depuis plusieurs
années un euro 50 je peux comprendre moi
j'ai deux frères médecins mais je peux
comprendre tranquillement que les gens
se disent franchement tout ça pour ça
ça donne pas le sentiment qu'on veut
mobiliser nos médecins si on veut mettre
un terme au désert médicaux faire en
sorte que les gens soient bien soignés
qu'ils aient confiance dans la médecine
on a besoin de retrouver y compris chez
les médecins s'est engagement et pour
retrouver cet engagement il faut les
respecter voilà
voudrait dire qu'il faudrait en fait
parler les négociations vont reprendre
dans quelques mois est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'il faudrait lâcher du lest
justement sur la rémunération des
médecins oui parce que vous ne pouvez
pas dire aux gens accepter plus de
contraintes accepter plus de patience et
leur dire bah alors si seulement si vous
acceptez si vous aurez trois francs 6 ou
plus la considération aussi d'un corps
et en l'occurrence du corps médical est
nécessaire on les a beaucoup sollicités
pendant le covid on a trouvé tout à fait
normal que les infirmières que les
brancardiers que les médecins soient
engagés 24 heures sur 24 franchement ça
vaut plus qu'un euro 50 merci beaucoup
Hélène pommier on regarde la une du
populaire du centre sortir de la Sécu
c'est la question que vous posez à la
Une de votre journal merci d'avoir été
avec nous à un mot Roger caoutchi sur un
autre texte que le Seigneur va examiné
après la réforme des retraites vous
enchaîner sur la loi immigration ce sera
à partir du 28 mars alors d'un côté il y
a des mesures de durcissement et de un
type de séjour provisoire pour les
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
est-ce que là-dessus en compromis avec
le gouvernement est possible non non
sauf si le gouvernement renonce un
certain de mesures vous parlez de de
cette espèce de régularisation en
réalité sur les métiers en tension c'est
non c'est non parce que moi j'ai fait
voter au Sénat il y a déjà plusieurs
années notion de quota en disant voilà
le Parlement défini les besoins de
l'économie française et on établit des
quotas sur les difficultés à recruter et
on fait venir et on accepte de faire
venir ce qui correspondrait ça mais là
on nous dit bah non ils sont en
situation irrégulière ils sont déjà sur
le territoire et le gouvernement le
gouvernement pas le Parlement décide
quels sont les métiers en tension sans
débat
quels sont les quotas ou les conditions
de régularisation c'est non parce que
c'est la porte ouverte à dire qu'est-ce
qui va définir le métier en tension le
gouvernement seul c'est non donc c'est
ce point que il y a ça
pour moi qui était longtemps rapporteur
sur l'immigration le fait de dire dès
que vous déposez votre demande d'asile
et nous sommes à 130 140 000 par an
demandeur d'asile vous pouvez avoir un
job vous voulez m'expliquer le type il a
un job immédiatement et vous allez
l'expulser après si vous lui donnez pas
le droit d'asile or on donne le droit
d'asile qu'en gros à 25%, les 75 autres
pour cent s'ils ont pris un job et si
vous leur accordez pas le droit d'asile
ils vont vous dire mais moi je travaille
mais moi j'ai un job et le chef
d'entreprise viendra dire bah attendez
donc on nous met dans des situations
insupportables et donc c'est pas la
peine de faire comme ça donc c'est non
alors si le gouvernement nous dit
là-dessus il y a de la marge de
discussion on peut pouvoir transmettre
au Parlement le pouvoir etc d'un certain
nombre de sujets on verra mais si le
gouvernement ne bouge pas je ne voterai
pas ce texte merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été notre invité pendant cette
première demi-heure dans 20 minutes on
continue évidemment à parler de la
réforme des retraites on ira à
Saint-Étienne ou les syndicats se sont
réunis hier pour mobiliser contre la
réforme on sera avec telle cette la télé
locale de Saint-Étienne et d'abord on
poursuit évidemment notre émission
spéciale réforme des retraites c'est
Patrick canard qui va que du bonheur